alors quelqu'un a fait l'amour dans un
ascenseur on doit deviner qui sait alors
on doit devenir attention c'est pas
supra original non plus ouais
Maxime allez il a une tête coquin là
en même temps Maxime dans votre cas
c'est franchement tu habites au 4e
rez-de-chaussée 4e
c'était un petit ascenseur et qui nous
conservé que deux étages et le sous-sol
donc ça a duré 10 secondes mais ça me va
très bien
précoce
de mettre des mots
merci beaucoup merci Monsieur
séquences là alors
c'est pas moi c'est Ludivine on a gagné
avec son chéri
je n'ai jamais fait l'amour
la couleur
on arrive pas à trouver c'est tout
pareil complètement
improbable ils avaient tu nous avais
caché ça
m'aurait pas coûté mais non c'est pas
moi qui est le mytho du plateau non non
non non
ça peut être partagé une sucette
c'est pas moi non la malle la malle
c'est vous non
c'est qui c'est qui
la personne c'est toi
non c'est une blague
en numéro alors moi je veux savoir qui a
fait l'amour dans les loges de PNP c'est
sûr
[Rires]
assez peu globalement moi je viens tout
le temps c'est pas moi donc c'est vous
ça se voit
parce que mon chéri m'accompagne souvent
je vous mets un billet je vous mets un
billet que cette personne en question
n'est pas son mari actuelle je vous mets
un billet je parierai très gros oh ça va
être fan du commentaire
dans un champ je serai fidèle moi ça va
pas non mais je dis ça
c'est pas possible que ça soit moi sauf
que moi j'ai dit sur des barbelés
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon dans un
champ de la chance
[Applaudissements]
sur l'imprimante
qu'il avait déclenché on a eu toutes les
photos alors ça moi j'ai fait ça je
faisais ça à l'école mon grand jeu et
j'étais viré pour ça je il y avait une
photocopieuse
donc dans la forêt ça c'est bon c'est
pas très original
dans la forêt peut-être Florian moi je
dirais
alors dans la forêt de Bois de Boulogne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans une chambre sous-marine à Punta
Cana alors
tout le temps normal
pour prendre le tel qui est sous la
terre
il y avait des nuits comme ça très bien
c'est sympa c'est très beau
de TPMP en haut
on en rajoutez pas à la plage alors ça
je préviens que les gens qui nous
regardaient les plus jeunes c'est très
dangereux pensez aux pensées au papier
de verre
du coup Ludivine non c'est Hugo je pense
non non
ça fait mal hein franchement c'était un
vrai fantasme c'est vrai que le sable
du plaisir c'est l'ennemi bah c'est
l'ennemi des c'est ce qu'on dit mais
pour du ça dans le moteur
ça marche beaucoup moins bien et pour la
beauté du geste ou la beauté du geste
c'est sympa pour le geste alors à la
place alors dans l'avion ça c'est un
grand classique mais vous savez comment
on appelle les gens qui qui font l'amour
dans un avion non les planeurs
[Applaudissements]
mais non mais non
on appelle ça les gens qui font partie
du club 10000 c'est quoi ça 10 000
mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
et fougueux là maintenant je suis un
vieil homme mais c'était sur à Paris
Bangkok et puis c'est le steward il m'a
demandé poulet poulet au beurre bon j'ai
senti qu'il avait l'air intéressé puis
quand la nuit est tombée
[Rires]
alors parce que vous êtes dans les
avions il y a une cabine qui est
au-dessus
de visiter
voilà c'est tout seul c'est assez
pratique vous l'avez peut-être
pas déranger bien bien évidemment donc
c'était un soir
j'aime bien la vie c'est très bien et on
a fini là
je vous jure je vous tape mais je vous
montre
c'est toi
[Applaudissements]
de mariage donc si on peut passer à
autre chose je suis sur une phase de
mariage donc si on peut passer très vite
mariage
c'est pas grave
vous avez une vie avant bien sûr bah oui
c'était avec une ex oui effectivement
elle m'a rejoint à la chicha
effectivement et bah disons qu'on a la
changer de tuyau quoi
merci
[Applaudissements]
votre mère voit l'émission là
bonjour Maman et puis comment s'appelle
votre maman elle s'appelle Barta
d'ailleurs elle est très célèbre sur Tik
Tok alors
je l'ai commencé
ouais exactement mais bon aux Antilles
il fait très chaud une envie pressante
et puis le petit fantasme de voir sans
être vu c'était formidable au
desserts
alors j'ai tellement de restaurant vous
êtes au dessert
tarte au citron
j'ai le sens du détail
en fait vous êtes curieux c'est ça